JOSE ALCERRECA: Welcome to
this video about the access
management API.
I'm Jose Alcerreca, and
I'm here with Nick Johnson.
NICK JOHNSON: Hi.
I am machine that
turns copy into code.
And I write the AdSense app
for iPhone here at Google.
JOSE ALCERRECA: Thanks
for coming, Nick.
First of all, can you
show us a demo of the app?
NICK JOHNSON: Sure.
So if we start here
on the overview page
that you'll see when
you open the app,
you have key values
for the important time
spans with deltas against
appropriate comparisons.
Tap one of these and go through,
see other important metrics
for the same time period,
as well as a graph.
Tapping the other
metrics, you can
see those displayed as well.
If we put this in landscape
you can swipe again and also
hold a single
simulated, in this case,
finger down to examine
a value, or two fingers
if you want to
compare two values.
So if I go back to
the side menu here,
you can see we also
have the majority
of the reports from
the AdSense homepage.
So if I select one of
these entirely at random--
I'll go with countries--
you can see a bar graph
of your performance across
different countries.
We can go into landscape
to examine a value.
Or if you want to see this data
as a pie chart, just swipe this
and you get a nice
transformation.
JOSE ALCERRECA: Wow.
NICK JOHNSON: Thank you.
Yeah.
Here, you can tap
for a landscape
to go through the same thing.
JOSE ALCERRECA: Great.
OK.
So you're obviously using
the AdSense Management API.
But are you using the Google
Client Libraries for this?
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
I'm using the Google
Client Library
for Objective C for
all of the requests.
JOSE ALCERRECA: OK.
And I know for each page
you just use one request
or you just make one request.
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
That's correct.
JOSE ALCERRECA:
How do you do that?
NICK JOHNSON: Well,
actually, as an example,
if we go back to the overview
here, what you could do is
you could request this entire
time span as individual days
and then I add all
the numbers together.
But you don't want to
do that, because you
can suffer rounding errors.
The API will only return you
with accuracy down to the cent
or down to the
penny, in this case.
So you want to use the
total of each report
for each one of these values.
So that's a total
of eight values.
What we do is we collect
all these together
into a batch, which allows
us to basically take
a list of requests and get
a list of responses back.
Objective C Client
Library has support
for several different
kinds of call backs.
And in Objective C,
you can use something
called a block, which is
essentially a closure.
So every single value that
comes back, our call back gets
called, updates the data.
And then the batch
query has a nice feature
where you can set
an additional block
to be called right at the end,
which then updates the display.
JOSE ALCERRECA: Great.
Are you also using
the cache layer?
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
Another benefit of
using adjacent API
is that each
request and response
is essentially a string-- so
a very simple key value cache.
JOSE ALCERRECA: You
actually store the response?
NICK JOHNSON: Yes.
JOSE ALCERRECA: OK.
That's cool.
All right.
So when developers start
coding for the management
API for any APIs at Google, they
have to readjust to the project
first.
For iOS, what are the options?
Because you have install
application, web application.
NICK JOHNSON: It's the web
application and service
count on option.
And you have to go with
an installed application.
Just a regular other
installed application
will work just fine.
But for extra security, you
can use the iOS specific option
that's available there as well.
JOSE ALCERRECA: OK.
Great.
And what about performance?
Do you have to do anything
special to imporve it?
NICK JOHNSON: Batching
is the main thing.
An improved
performance means you
don't have to worry so
much about synchronization.
And happily, just about
everything else we
need is provided by
the Client Library
by Core Animation in iOS itself
and excellent open source
library called
NimbusKit, which we use.
JOSE ALCERRECA: OK.
That's great.
OK.
Thank you very much
for your time, Nick,
and congrats on an awesome job.
NICK JOHNSON: Thank
you very much.
JOSE ALCERRECA: OK.
See you later.